est ce que vous connaissez l'histoire de
monsieur greu qui a dormi quatre heures
7 lits pour prendre un train 7 heures du
mat et qui est vient d'éclater
magnifique bon aujourd'hui je peux
amener quelque chose de cool jeu un peu
comme tous les jours j'espère samsung
galaxy tab samsung a sorti deux
nouvelles tablettes cette année
la table est 5e déjà présenté il ya
quelques jours alors si vous n'êtes pas
vu la vidéo je suis tout de suite allé
la voir
et celle-là la table alors la tabac
c'est plus pour le côté famille
familiale d'ailleurs il le met sur la
botte sur votre suite il faut mettre
vraiment en avant l'appli keats hommes
vous avez une application pour les
vendre c'est une tablette familiale
c'est pas forcément la tablette qu'on va
prendre pour les usages professionnels
qu'on va prendre pour pour bosser pour
laquelle un petit peu exigeants assez
rapide ça c'est la tablette pour vous
regarder quelques séries des films pour
naviguer sur internet pour visionner vos
réseaux sociaux
c'est la tablette que vous êtes pouvant
laisser si vous êtes parents à vos
enfants avec l'espace enfants pour
qu'ils puissent avoir leur petit univers
tranquillement sécurisé c'est une
tablette qui va pas être
particulièrement exigeante
on n'a pas d'écran amoled on n'a pas un
truc de fou mais on a un produit qui est
convenable qui est correct
[Musique]
dans la grande famille des tablettes
vous avez différents produits vous allez
avoir je dirais le produit vraiment
d'entrée de gamme
on va pas aller chez samsung cherche et
se sont produits la tablette entourent
100 euros tablette pas forcément de
qualité à incroyable que vous allez
prendre pour regarder quelques séries
voilà on va pas lui en demander c'est
pas ta est faible on a monté tout un
petit peu en gamme entre 200 à 300 euros
on est sur cette typologie de tablets et
des tablettes qui auront des rendu
correct qui seront sont toutes assez
équilibré bien mais pour l' usage
familial multimédia lance tu auras
monter une tablette un poil plus
exigeante avec un poil plus de
performances on va pouvoir aller faire
un peu plus de multitâche pouvoir à
travailler par exemple si vous êtes
étudiant et bien pour pour de la prise
de notes
vous avez une autre application qui
travaillent davantage de fonds on
cherche un peu plus de performance à
dessus on va et ce notamment sur la
galaxy tab est 5e
ensuite vous allez arriver sur les
tablettes qui sont tous en usage
professionnel comme propos retrouver par
exemple chez apple sur l'ipad pour moi
vous fait un petit peu le dessin
l'univers grosso modo des tablettes et
cette tablette à et blake la table ac il
ya beaucoup de talent dans tout ça cette
fameuse tablette allait elle est cool
parce qu'elle se positionne vraiment le
temps de la voilà vous voulez commencer
à voir une tablette voulait pas mettre
énormément d'argent mais vous voulez un
produit de qualité un produit qui quand
même plutôt pas mal qui est pas
forcément hyper polyvalent pour usage
professionnel familial on est vraiment
sur un usage familial mais qui par
contre ce rachat fait le fera
correctement
gardez vous allez pas mal je vraiment
vrai plus près rapide tour de la boîte
pour voir tes intérieur petite pochette
assez qualitatif ça c'est bien ici bloc
de recharge votre câble usb usb c'est
vos petits écouteurs et oui ça c'est
plutôt cool vous avez des écouteurs est
mince ici vous retrouvez une petit dock
et voilà on a fait le tour
moi déjà j'aime bien je trouve que en un
format qui est assez grand ça vous fait
un écran qui est effectivement assez
long j'aime bien ce typologie de
produits tout ça c'est sympa on a un
produit qui soit assez qualitatif tout
des finitions en aluminium par contre je
trouve un petit peu l'eau c'est la
première impression lorsque j'ai eu la
main aux îles cas elle n'est pas toute
légère en termes de finition par contre
un boulot qui est bien fait vous avez
une petite démarcation vous avez
notamment au 3 août avec votre caméra
arrière qui hélas pas de lecteur
d'empreintes digitales
le branding samsung c'est simple c'est
efficace et jolie un écran l'avant avec
une petite zone pour votre caméra ici
vous retrouver ici votre bouton pour
allumer votre bouton de volume votre
petit tiroir ici pour venir mettre votre
carte micro sd vous avez deux haut
parleurs un haut parleur de chaque côté
votre prise ici en usb c'est pour venir
la recharger de l'autre côté absolument
rien ce que je trouve assez cool avec
cette tva c'est qu'on se retrouve un peu
dans l'esprit premium qu'on a notamment
avec la galaxy tab est 5 e on le
retrouve dans la table à l a pas vu tout
un peu cheap pour voir qu'on est quand
même sur un produit qui est moins cher
et si je vous disais ya pas de capteur
d'empreintes digitales
il n'ya pas non plus de fun love ou le
déverrouiller avec un code pin avec un
schéma est ce que vous voulez quand vous
le regardez comme ça c'est vrai qu'elle
est assez honnêtes pour trouver quand
même des bordures qui sont un peu grande
sur le haut et sur le bas sur les côtés
c'est assez relativement fin c'est
plutôt bien
l'écran est pas ou feint on a un écran
lcd c'est du tft salle écran de 10,1
pouces résolution 1920 par 1200 pixels à
224 pixels par pouce c'est pas le le
produit on a vraiment eu effect avec un
écran complètement dingue à côté de ça
je trouve quand même suffisamment
lumineux je trouve bien relativement
bien calibré bien travaillé auprès de la
personne font glace du pouvoir qu'on
n'est pas sur une dalle ip est moins sûr
du tft ça va c'est relativement bien
maîtrisé de la partie ça c'est un très
bon point je vous dit à moi pour me
regarder des films des séries lazio -
vous êtes tranquille d'un point de vue
visuel c'est vrai qu'on a quand même ses
grands vendeurs sur les côtés mais il
fait plus on est sur une tablette qui va
pas chez les êtres et hyper hyper cher
ça fonctionne assez pas hallucinant mais
ça fonctionne par contre un truc qui
nous dérange un peu sur l'expérience
quand vous tenez comme ça c'est
l'expérience audio parce que vous avez
deux haut parleurs
ici on pourrait donc je dis on a deux
haut parleurs donc on a un son stéréo
sauf que lorsque vous prenez votre
tablette comme ça vous n'avez pas une
source stéréo même si vous avez une
diffusion en stéréo par là c'est bien
lorsque vous prenez votre tablette et
que vous regardez comme ça là vous avez
sensation stéréo mais avec des
haut-parleurs qui tient à peu vers le
bas donc on n'est pas dans un truc assez
immersif a contrario ce qui aurait été
assez intéressant bon on retrouve dans
d'autres tablettes a beaucoup plus haut
de gamme notamment sur la galaxy tab et
5 peu ça aurait été de mettre un haut
parleur là et on parle là du coup
lorsque vous regardez votre série film
vous jouez vous faites ce que vous
voulez ça vous regarde ne pas savoir
vous positionnez comme ça vous
imagineriez
bien avoir un haut parleur là un haut
parleur l'a aidé à avoir un côté un peu
plus immersif avec un côté un peu plus
spatialisé ce que vous n'avez pas comme
ça là vous l'avez en face de vous vous
avez votre sang qui sortent ce côté là
basta donc c'est vrai que l'intérêt en
tout cas d'avoir deux haut parleurs
olterre très facilement de ce côté là on
aura un regain de puissance mais on perd
l'effet spatialisation à côté de ça
prend jouent à des jeux franchement
c'est vrai que c'est assez sympa à la
canton n'éclate pas tout les bagnoles
la qualité est franchement correct donc
c'est vrai que pour une sensation de
gaming pour jouer à des jeux familiaux
c'est vraiment très sympa comme ça mais
si on veut vraiment profité d'une bonne
expérience de jeu de ce que vous voulez
vous utilisez ça parce que vous avez ici
une prise jack 3.5 donc ça c'est
vraiment cool
et là vous profiter davantage d'une
meilleure expérience audio vous avez du
dolby 3d enfin tout cas c'est cool et en
plus derrière si vous connaissez un
petit peu le lot est ce qui est optimisé
ses one eye de samsung qui trouve sur un
envoi 9 paille
vous savez que ça marche parfaitement
bien vous avez plein de réglages qui
sont très qualitatif et qui du coup
renforce l'expérience audio et cottin
plus immersif un peu immersif
c'est je parle très très mal français à
côté un peu immersif donc là tout de
suite
la qualité est quand même vachement
mieux le spectre est correct alors c'est
pas là où on va avoir le meilleur sont
restitués même au niveau du casque j'ai
connu des des produits que ce soit aux
redoutables f qui vous restitue un son
de bien meilleure qualité mais c'est
vrai que je trouve que malgré tout si on
la conscience qu'on n'est pas sur le
produit le plus exigeant comme galaxy
tab est 5e on aura bien meilleure
expérience au niveau de l'audio on a
quand même quelque chose qui est très
honnête de bonne qualité moi je vous
conseille franchement que ce soit pour
jouer un jeu ou pour aux cages et où des
décisions des films de guerre m casque
alors attention
j'ai eu une fois de plus pas d' écoute
prolongée aux castes attention mettez
pas le son trop fort ne pas se rendre
sourds sont très très très important
mais c'est vrai que l'expérience est
quand même nettement meilleure côté
performances on est sur un produit qui
tient la route qui n'est pas le plus
rapide du monde
on tourne sur un exil au 7900 4 on a
deux gigas de ram 32 gigas de stockage
en natif c'est pas énorme ce que je
conseille vraiment c'est de venir a
ajouté avec une petite extension est
mort avec votre carte micro sd que vous
venez insérez ici vous pouvez monter
jusqu'à 512
giga alors vous n'êtes pas forcément
besoin de 500 gigas et vous montez au
moins un minimum à 128 vous allez
pouvoir stocker davantage de choses à
l'intérieur
dites vous bien par contre tout ce qui
est application tout ce qui va venir
faire tourner votre tablette vous
n'allez pas pouvoir en mettre beaucoup
trop vous avez 32 gigas c'est pas énorme
alors réfléchissez bien avant d'aller
sur ce produit là à ce que vous allez
installer aux usages que vous allez
avoir moi qui par contre est vachement
bien sûr cette tablette c'est
l'autonomie
vous avez une très grosse batterie de
6150 milliampères heures qui se
rechargent bien évidemment en usb type c
je regretterai qu'il n'y ait pas de
recharge rapide là dessus ce qui ce
qu'il faut quand même prendre son mal en
patience
3h30 4h tranquille tranquille ou de 0 à
100% donc bon voila vous vous la
recharge et pas aux orages mais doit
pour dans dix minutes page la charge et
non ces gens ça va prendre beaucoup de
temps à côté de ça l'autonomie et bien
vous enfin ça l'est pour une fois de
plus de vos usages pour moi une
autonomie de deux jours là dessus c'est
pas déconner alors vas pas l'utiliser
forcément deux jours en usage prolongé
donc vous allez pouvoir la garder
plusieurs jours en regardant des séries
et des films le soir tranquillement je
trouve vraiment que l'autonomie c'est
vraiment un très gros point fort pour
cette galaxy tab à 1
alors il ya un autre point j'ai passé
très très vite dessus parce que pour moi
c'est pas du tout faits pour ça
néanmoins c'est là donc on en parle vous
avez deux caméras une caméra de 8
mégapixels
j'ai absolument aucune information sur
une ouverture ceci étant dit pour son
affiche un petit peu et vous avez une
caméra à l'avant qu'une caméra de 5
mégapixels
je vous dis très clairement c'est parti
pour faire des photos
donc si vous voyez quelque chose c'est
vraiment important de prendre en photo
vous prenez en photo sinon prenez vos
smartphones c'est pas du tout un produit
qui fait pour faire des photos pour ne
vous aurait pas sa puissance pour faire
des jeux en réalité augmentée donc vous
en fichez un petit peu tout ça c'est la
voilà donc on en parle mais vous ferait
pas grand chose si vous voulez filmer
quelques souvenirs profil mais jusqu'en
full hd en 30 images par seconde
mais au-delà de ça il faut oublier les
caméras clairement en plus ce qui est
cool c'est que vous avez en plus du
bluetooth 5.0 donc si vous voulez
appareiller très facilement que des
petits galaxie buzz pour venir écouter
de la musique pour regarder
des séries ce que vous voulez son fils
ça marche bien c'est rapide c'est facile
donc ça c'est plutôt cool donc
maintenant à la question
à la question c'est pas le plus
important on se concentre je veux
acheter une tablette je veux me faire
plaisir je me mettais ma première
tablette où je veux renouveler ma
tablette est ce que cette galaxy tab à
et fait pour moi alors je vous le dis
une fois de plus je l' ai déjà dit mais
je vous le redis c'est nous on est plus
important pour un usage familial non
exigeants vous n'allez pas voir beaucoup
d'application très gourmande vous pouvez
y aller
vous y allez vous jouer à des jeux comme
un sac ni trop vous aller tranquille ne
pensais pas faire tourner des choses
avaient besoin de 3d je vous ai besoin
de performances des jeux qui vont
prendre beaucoup de place vous avec 32
gigas de stockage donc les jeux un giga
et quelques et compagnie vous allez voir
plusieurs vous oubliez ça n'ira pas les
applications qu'ils étaient grossir
aussi dans le temps et de peser plus en
plus lourdes vous oubliez pensez
vraiment à ça en terme de stockage
quelques petits jeux pour la famille du
visionnage de vidéos du contenu qu'un
petit peu ludique comme ça ça va c'est
bien on a besoin d'applications un peu
plus lourde c'est pas fait pour vous
pour stocker par contre vous avez votre
carte d'extension de mémoire ça c'est
plutôt bien
la tablette en elle même je trouve assez
qualitative la trouve bien un poid lourd
mais ce n'est pas non plus très très
grave
l'écran pouvoir compter sur du tfc ça
marche c'est bien je trouve vraiment
vraiment honnête très honnête donc c'est
une tablette que vous allez acheter à
usage familial
vous allez acheter par exemple pour un
jeune c'est pour acheter pour un enfant
attention bon vendeur vous allez mettre
dessus aussi là peut-être ça vous avez
ou à nu avec toute la gestion bien
d'être numérique et compagnons cas c'est
vraiment intéressant pour pouvoir
mesurer pas passer trop de temps non
plus sur les écrans ça c'est bien
filtrer la lumière bleue c'est qu'il ya
pas mal de petites options là dedans qui
sont quand même bien et assez
sécurisante
lorsqu'on est parent pour des enfants si
c'est votre première tablette premier
achat vous pouvez y aller vous êtes
tranquille dans la mesure où j'avais
vraiment pris en considération les
problématiques des espaces de stockage
je pense que vous pouvez y aller c'est
un joli produit
il existe deux types de config alors je
parlais pris par coeur celle là comme
elle est là pour la trouve à 219 euros
voir un petit peu moins cher d'ailleurs
si elle vous intéresse je vous ai mis un
ou voir plusieurs liens en bas d'un
description pour aller jeter un petit
coup d'oeil mais c'est aussi une version
4g et pouvoir la voir en mobilité en
vous connectant à internet
on ya 279 euros je suis pas persuadé que
ça va du coup d'avoir la dernière son 4g
si vous avez votre smartphone si vous
avez un abonnement est bien au fait que
le partage de connexion
ça ira ça fonctionne bien selon son du
wifi pardon d'avis
c'est la meilleure configuration ah bah
voilà donc je trouve intéressant je
trouve bien dites moi ce que vous en
pensez vous est-ce que vous avez une
tablette de samsung oui non quoi comment
laquelle est ce que celle là vous la
trouve intéressante est ce que vous
pensez qu'elle vaut le coup à un peu
plus de 200 euros dalli se positionner
sur cette galaxy tab et à se qualifier
pour vous est-ce qu'il vous fait de
l'oeil oui non pas comment points
négatifs points positive ou marqué tout
ça comme ça c'est cool ça mettra un peu
à tout le monde de se faire un avis sur
ce produit en tout cas je vous dis voilà
moi je trouve honnête bien intéressante
à vous mes yeux ce que je pense et
surtout jean marc et demain ciao